good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can build
your confidence clip number three is my
personal favorite and make sure to stick
around to the end for some special bonus
clips also as you watch this video if
somebody says something that really
resonates with you make sure to write it
down in the comments below and put
quotes around it so that others can
benefit and be inspired as well I grew
up with no self confidence no self
esteem I kicked it was kicked out of
school several times I misbehaved I
ended up spending half of my school in
the library because I was kicked out of
courses I left school in the 12th grade
and got a job as a dishwasher worked as
a labourer lived in my car dug ditches
and things like that so I had no
self-esteem and I began studying the
subject over the years and I found that
your level of self confidence how much
confidence you have in yourself to be do
accomplish something really determines
the whole quality of your life so what I
found is that there's a direct
relationship between how high your level
of self confidence is and your level of
sales one-to-one relationship between
self confidence and selling success
because in selling you've got to be bold
you've got to be courageous you've got
to take rejection and disappointment
you've got to get out there you've got
to face all your fears in order to get
appointments you've got to face your
fears in order to ask for orders so self
confidence is critical self-confidence
is essential in business because it's
impossible even to start a business to
arrange a bank loan to set up customers
to hire people to do all the things that
are necessary in business require self
confidence also what we found is that
your level of self confidence is the
critical factor in your level sex-appeal
is that the more confidence you are the
more appealing you are to other people
the more confident you are actually the
more magnetism you have that's why
actors and actresses who seem to be
extremely confident have a certain
amount of magnetism so confidence not
only is really important for us it makes
us feel happy it effects and empowers
other people it causes people to treat
us differently we make more sales we
make more money we marry better we're
better and more effective socially
self-confidence is everything
you
the easiest way to build self-confidence
there's no magic button I can't say this
plane is going down who can fly it put
your hand up I can I'm confident
repetition repetition repetition right
what does Malcolm Gladwell call it the
10,000 hour rule there's no magic button
I recruited a goalie from Colombia South
America one year I big tall six foot
three man uh you know he had hands like
stone I thought he was like flipper
every time I throw him the ball down
down onto the ground I was like oh my
god we're in trouble
simple solution get to the wall kick a
ball against the wall and catch it kick
the ball against the wall and catch it
his goal was 350 a day for eight months
he came back his hands were callused the
moisture on his hands were literally
gone he is now playing in Europe magic
no repetition repetition repetition the
problem is we expect to be
self-confident but we can't be unless
the skill or the task we're doing is not
novel is not new to us we want to be in
a situation where we've created we've
had so much pressure in that and what I
mean because pressure builds diamonds we
want to be in the situation where hey
done this a thousand times I didn't my
speech I practice in front of the mirror
I thought hey I'm sounding good and then
I read in front of my kids and my and my
wife like oh gosh a little nervous then
I get in front of Glenn cool oh my
goodness I'm a little more nervous by
the time I get to the ACG we're 2,500
people can't say any more right 2,500
people
we're 2,500 people are there I won't
have a single ounce of nervousness
because of my ability to practice right
over and over and over again
the problem with repetition is how many
of us bail after the first bit of
failure how many us bail after the first
bit of adversity Edison was on that
video it depends who you ask is anywhere
from 1,000 to 10,000 tries to build that
lightbulb 1,000 to 10,000 JK Rowling
should be on that video you the army
publisher she took her Harry Potter book
to I believe the number was 12 or 13 I
don't I'm pretty confident but after two
or three knows I'd be like dang
after six or seven I'm like maybe not
definitely after nine or ten I'd be
looking to be a soccer coach or
something else beside it author right I
mean 12 times somebody said no but
practice practice practice and do not
accept failure maybe it shouldn't be
repetition maybe the answer should be
persistence because we all repeat
something but very few of us really will
persist so that's one way to build
self-confidence get out there do what
you want to do and accept and do not
accept no another technique that you can
do physically and that's to simply
change your physiology and when I say
physiology I'm talking about your
posture I'm talking about your head up
I'm talking about head straight maintain
eye contact that automatically sends a
signal to you of being more confident
try it out you're slouching in your
chair right now if you're sitting on
your couch like this watching this video
take a moment
sit up take a big breath breathing helps
as well a lot you have 80,000 messages
that transfer up your spinal cord into
your limbic system into your brain that
sends signals to your prefrontal cortex
that allows you to make effective
decisions now that's a miracle of
machine problem is most people hunched
over like this working at their computer
all day they're not moving enough then
they go to they sit in a car then they
come home then they're watching TV again
it's ridiculous elevate your posture my
friend lift it up
maintain eye contact put your head back
roll your shoulders back and allow those
signals to enter your brain so that you
can make effective decisions and overall
feel more confident because how you feel
what how you feel dictates who you are
it's all energy it's all vibration in
your emotion if you're going to be
successful in creating the life of your
dreams you have to believe that you are
capable of making it happen you have to
believe that you have the right stuff
and that you're able to pull it off now
whether you call it self esteem self
confidence or self assurance
it's a deep-seated belief that you have
what it takes
the abilities the inner resources the
talents and the skills to create your
desired results now believing in
yourself is simply an attitude believing
yourself is a choice you have to choose
to believe that you can do anything you
set your mind to anything at all because
in fact you can it might help you to
know that the latest brain research now
indicates with enough positive self-talk
and positive visualization combined with
proper training coaching and practice
anyone can learn to do almost anything
now I've interviewed thousands of
successful people and almost every one
of them has told me I was not the most
gifted or the most talented person in my
field but I chose to believe that
anything was possible
and because of that I studied I
practiced and I worked harder than the
others and that's how I got to where I
am
you know Ruben Gonzalez a 20 year old
living in Texas hot Texas can take up
the ludes which is a winter sport and
become an Olympic athlete if Bill Gates
who is a college dropout can become a
multi billionaire and Stephen Jay candle
who was a dyslexic student who failed
three grades in school can become a
best-selling author and a television
producer then you too can accomplish
anything if you'll simply believe it's
possible so make the decision right now
to believe that you create all of your
experiences because you do let's start
creating the ones you want by believing
you can sounds a little strange but
accepting this level of responsibility
is uniquely and inevitably empowering it
means you can do change and become
anything at all decide you need no
reason whatsoever to be more confident
just make the decision to be confident
you don't need a reason you don't need
50 people to tell you you're amazing or
you're beautiful or we love you you just
have to say you know what today I lift
my head up a little bit
you know today I'm gonna give myself a
little bit of credit today I'm just
gonna be confident I'm gonna walk into
this room I'm gonna stand tall as if I
was an incredibly confident person for
no other reason that that's my intention
right now that's it that's the power of
intention it's the power of the
self-directed human being that we can
just get to choose how we want to feel
you could be happy right now
for no reason right for no reason at all
you can just say you know what I'm just
I to be happy in my life you don't need
50 things to make you happy you just
sense the moment feel grateful for life
you're good to go
right we over complicate these things we
think we have to have you know some big
long psychological story and build up to
suddenly one day wake up and be more
confident no we don't we have to wake up
one more day and say today I'm be
confident just like we decide when to
wake up if you ever had a day where you
just I mean just crushed it you know you
got so much done you were like wow at
the end of the day or like man I just
crushed it today that happened because
when you woke up in the morning said I'm
gonna get some stuff done today you had
the intention to be a productive human
being that day so why not set the
intention to be a confident you and
being that day
why not sent the attention to be a
loving person or a vicious person or a
funny person or a flirty person or a
sexy person or whatever kind of person
that you ought to be just decide you
don't need a bunch of stuff people
really get this one wrong and what
happens is if you don't have the
intention in the moment say I'm going to
be confident I'm just gonna allow that
to come up I'm going to feel that sense
and feeling what confidence is for me
and express that genuinely and real for
myself within the vacuum of intention
arises impulse
and often from that impulse through our
brain stem up comes worry concerned
fear the de paying attention to what is
wrong so that we can fix it or flee or
escape right so we have to have the
intention of who you are and what we're
going to be it begins with you simply
deciding to be a confident person change
my life when I did that I realized it
and this was way back in college for me
I just thought I want to be a confident
person how's this going to happen do I
have to wait till I'm 50 after I've
achieved everything I've made some money
or maybe people like me somewhere come
on get over it we should get over our
stuff and one day just realize real
confidence is simply having the ability
to genuinely express who we truly are
and to pursue things that we truly
desire that's confidence confidence
doesn't have to mean you're leaping over
tall buildings confidence means you're
being who you are authentically for no
other reason no one gave you permission
you just decided to be who you are you
decided to chase your dreams that's
confidence right believing in yourself
and believing where you're going that's
confidence it doesn't take a whole lot
of magic that's confidence confidence is
the key to so many things confidence is
so closely related its mistaken for
arrogance
Muhammad Ali wanted one of my idols as a
kid probably home was a kid
this guy was so confident and his
ability it was mistake as arrogance but
he was so sure
so coming that he cannot be beat I have
experienced that type of conflict when I
told you I walked into a competition and
I would ask which one of you is coming
in second I've met bad I wasn't totally
totally confident that whoever showed up
was coming in second how do you develop
that type of confidence is through
obsession obsession you after the
obsessed with whatever you're trying to
obtain in order to develop it you're
obsessed with tiddlywinks you're
obsessed with hopscotch obsessed with
pulling teeth obsessed with trimming
edges why should this is whatever though
you do if you want to be very confident
in it you must become obsessed with
however they was my passion my obsession
and I develop through hard as what I
knew without a shadow God did that next
me had not worked as hard as I had work
I couldn't be matched in my desire my
want my drive my will those areas I
could not be touch it wasn't human
Glenn who get max removes it so having
that confidence total confidence and my
ability is no way I can lose it if no I
convinced myself that I was invincible
convince yourself that you cannot lose
convince yourself that you are the best
convince yourself convince yourself that
nobody came out will you nobody cannot
want you convince yourself or those
things in you what happens convince
yourself that you can't be started for
me confidence comes down to two things
first is having done it before if you've
done something before then it's a lot
easier to do it again but an easy segue
from that is if you have done a smaller
version of it then you have a little bit
more confidence where a lot of people
have these big goals and because it's
such a big goal that they're here and
they want to get here it looks like such
a big chasm it's such a big void that
you have to cross that it's scary you
don't have a lot of confidence in
yourself but if you start here you want
to get to here this may not be your next
goal this might be the ultimate goal but
not the next goal start here through
that little step and then that little
step and that little step and every time
you take a little step it gives you
confidence to go off and do the next
step because that next step isn't as big
and as scary as jumping all the way to
the top and you'll eventually get here
and when you look back it wasn't this
big scary impossible thing because you
built confidence every step along the
way the other thing that really helps me
with confidence is remembering the
mission and not wanting to live with
regret any time I'm afraid
any time I don't feel confident I
imagine myself on my deathbed looking
back on my life and thinking am I going
to regret this this thing that I'm
afraid of right now
am I going to regret this when I'm dying
to say I should have taken that
opportunity I shouldn't have been afraid
I should have gone for it and
remembering that giving that kind of
context in perspective doesn't eliminate
the fear just helps it be put in better
perspective and gives me the confidence
to just push through it's feeling that
fee
and doing it anyway
so that's my take I love to know what
you think about confidence I'd love to
know what you thought of this video did
it help you what did you learn from it
leave in the comments below and I will
join in the discussion I made this
addition a belief like on confidence
because Sandell alipin asked me to so
there's a topic you like me to cover in
a future episode of believe life leave
it in the comments below I don't see
what I can do finally what they give a
quick shout-out to Thaksin thank you so
much for buying a copy of my book really
means a lot to me thank you for that
support rules you watchin if you want to
change at a shout-out in a future video
make sure to pick up a copy of my book
we really mean a lot to me and then send
in your receipts so we can keep track
and also send you the bonuses thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you soon
confidence is like a mental muscle like
muscle everyone is born with it but not
everyone flexes it and if you want your
muscles to grow stronger God exercise so
here are my exercising tips consciously
think positive thoughts especially
during moments when you're feeling down
so take a deep breath and remind
yourself that life is too short and you
got to make the best of it listen to
music that will lift your mood a good
beat and sound has been proven to help
people in a positive way music and sound
has been known to help the growth of
plants that says a lot you want to have
a healthy habit of maintaining this
mental muscle but you also don't want to
overdo it everything in moderation
balance is key it's good to remind
yourself from time to time how worthy
and how you know awesome you are but you
also want to leave room to grow and
improve I mean we can all change and
evolve for the better hey grant cardone
here talking to you today about some
self-confidence where do you get your
self-confidence you can't buy it at the
store folks can't dress it up can't eat
it you can't buy it
you can't even manufacture it yourself
you have to go build self-confidence
this this is a topic that's near and
dear to my heart okay because I remember
being 25 years old scared to death of
people 29 years old started my speaking
career terrified of the people I had to
go to didn't call on anybody for a year
because I was literally frozen in fear
and one day said somebody said something
to me do you need you need to handle
your self-confidence issue so I went
bought a suit and I didn't feel any
better I went bought a card didn't feel
any better about myself I mean I felt a
little better for a second look
self-confidence is the only outfit you
can't buy this is an inside job you got
to study you got to learn you got to
practice and you have to you have to do
the hard things self confidence comes
from repeating experiences that are
difficult same place courage comes from
you know the guy that does something
this courageous is given the title of
being courageous
it's not because he went war courageous
it's because he went did something look
if you want to build self-confidence you
can listen to the subliminal tapes it's
not going to work you can go do
hypnotism it's freakin ridiculous you
need to be more aware more alert and you
need to do more some of the ideas that
people are thrown at you guys right now
to build your self-confidence you're
going to eat different and feel better
you're going to do this and feel look
you need to get in front of people do
the things you're scared to do to get
the self-confidence you want to have
period it's not on sale it's not at
Bloomingdale's Macy's it's not a Toyota
it's not on the radio dude it's an
inside job I can't help you with it
you got to take what I'm giving you in
these blurbs blabs streams scopes cats
whatever you're calling it the posts the
streams the instagrams and then I need
to take that and start applying it in my
life otherwise you're going to find
yourself feeling worse and worse and
worse about yourself you want to go walk
on fire go do it
is that going to build yourself
confidence I doubt it okay I doubt it
man go spend a grand on a weekend that
will not improve your self-confidence
the only thing I know for sure that will
change your sense of self is the actions
you take getting in front of other
people other people people you don't
know people you're scared to talk to
you're sitting there trembling through
your pitch until you don't tremble
anymore self-confidence an inside job
it's not a suit you put on it's not a
car you drive this is not something you
buy this is something you develop we all
have a self-talk tape that plays in our
head anybody go shopping and put on a
pair of pants this week if you're a
woman the first thing that always comes
damn I look fat in these pants and if
you're a man it's the opposite oh god I
have no muscle I'm so flabby right we
all have this tape that plays in our
head as a student if they ask me the
question it was like gosh gee please
please professor don't pick me I don't
know the answer I don't put I look down
right if you're in a when I let me tell
you something and the VP of Business
Administration I shouldn't repeat this
but when they hired me as an athletic
director I sat in an architect's meeting
and I am as bowed as dumb as a post when
it comes to anything to do with numbers
and angles
and they're like the Funday bellator
valve of the architectural they're there
what do you think dr. Joseph uh let me
look into that for you and get back to
you right I was in us God God please
don't ask me please don't ask me we all
have this negative self-talk that goes
in our head guess what there's enough
people that are telling us we can't do
it that we're not good enough why do we
want to tell ourselves that we know for
a fact that thoughts influence actions
we saw it there with the with the video
Sheldon dr. Levey sewed right we know
that our thoughts influence actions why
do we want to say that negative
self-talk to ourselves we need to get
our own self affirmations Muhammad Ali
what was his self affirmation I am the
greatest who else is going to tell you
they need to be quiet moments in your
bedroom quiet moments when you're
brushing your teeth that we need to
reaffirm I am the captain of my ship and
the master of my fate that is my
affirmation I came from a school of
1,000 people I lived in a town of 1,000
people for 15 years there's no reason
that I should be in charge of national
deck department building Maple Leaf
Gardens but I am the captain of my ship
and the master of my fate if I don't say
it if I don't believe it
no one else will how do you build
self-confidence get away from the people
who will tear you down there's enough of
that
Muhammad Ali I am the greatest there is
no one better than me it's a difference
between hubris and ego and false pride
it's just reminding yourself in quiet
silent moments I put it down on a list
it's right beside my mirror right about
all the things that make me who I am
because I make enough mistakes and the
newspapers will recognize it and people
around me will recognize it and they'll
tear me down
and pretty soon I'll begin to believe it
there was a time when my confidence was
really low there was a time when I took
this job when I came from Iowa
I don't know if I could do it I had to
bring out my self-confidence letter a
letter I wrote to myself when I was
feeling good
Ivan congratulations on getting your PhD
before 40 congratu I am 40 under
congratulations on winning a national
championship good job on raising three
good kids and marrying the right woman I
wrote a letter to myself it was my own
brag sheet my own letter about the
things I was proud of because there are
moments and we'll all experience them in
our career in our life and our job
hunting and our relationships when we
are not feeling good about who and what
and where we are and I had to bring out
that letter and read it time and time
again for a period of about two weeks to
whether me through that storm it was
important stop the self-talk the
negative self-talk if you'll watch
you'll see some athletes they'll have a
little bandage or a little balm brand
around them Lance Armstrong is a perfect
one what's his self affirmation
LIVESTRONG isn't a brand it was to
remind them of who he was
LIVESTRONG then it came a brand he would
move that from one arm to the next arm
when belt and fare came into his mind
LIVESTRONG put it on there let's go
we'll all have it replace it